counter logic gaming will enter week 6
of the 2017 na LCS summer split in first
place while things are looking up for
them
this team has definitely had their fair
share of ups and downs so in honor of
their journey we put together the best
of CLG throughout the years initially I
wanted counter logic gaming to be more
of a community than a team that's where
we started field sheet we're like ok we
have this cool community the name is
awesome
logos awesome let's kind of just attach
the two together and make it happen
and it looks like Fuji are just finally
pushing their advantage down yes because
you just want to end it right here
taking a second necklace silicon GOG the
champions of the Intel Extreme Masters
global challenge in Cologne prodigious
drop here they go they get the kill on
Ezreal right away so 5 before Big Foot
I'll be not a good place as well try to
burn down and ignite does take him
hotshot with a double kill so far and
they're going to keep moving forward
triple kill make that and now on the
dragon or get hot choc negative
quadrants could also go down very low
the students a nice going any classes
there but the opening he has the
ultimate still on boy boy hits again
forced to back out the binding lands on
to double if I make that just nuking
night Jackie once again a hotshot hiding
in the back of the parapet as double is
destroyed saint vicious elements trying
to get hot that out of there off is
trying to clean up outside it's able to
take off Scott does that vision with
those extra sapling you sit around
waiting for night showing it which
applied the ezio the Savior's poignant
got to pick up a baron Divac you driving
in the open and there goes the first and
Oh from Jerusalem able to patronage a
cottonmouth the LG is going to escape
down the red ochre gaming business clean
up from stencil mm finger up could he
get a triple kill couple more days we'll
do a website popping is known into along
in his life like that bear but hotshot
out smiting faint mission and the rest
of the LG just leaning up make something
happen in this 45 situation where the
powers are fighting the buggers there
there's the headbutt but a fried
tortilla Robin Wow look at that first
now the game is over
ignite going down cops getting low will
he go down what were able to do a double
to take about Sullivan study absolutely
everybody he cleanses he decided he's
cooking corner with the F key elements
getting exhausted and he is going of
course it does holy moly what a finish
yet for the doober Infante on a stage
they move on yep qualified the triptych
for you is worth everything they've
worked so hard for
they're going in autopsy be almost
immediately pop positive and turned out
to the rifle big prize hoping to get
everyone away from him it's just going
to lay the indelible what boy why are
they live in the Darwin hot shot those
living oil
[Applause]
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay good god everything happens at 1:35
payday feel Jesus pull off some crazy
crazy business
CLG right off the bat here is with
really a new roster if you haven't seen
them since the end of season two chances
moved to the jungle
they've out to think of a new support
off remove formerly the ad carry from
fear and I've got Lincoln out in the mid
lane replacing big fat LP oh there it is
they're going for the exhaust goes down
and expresses the dazzle was there in
the final hits will be for double if
first blood for CLG regains health and
they look for the reinitiation on the
fight outs top of our heads for Reginald
makes it out but he flashes into the
fight to throw down intervention on
himself way too early into the fight but
they may have enough damage here with
the amount of people just piled on no
it's going to be CLG they're just
turning this around an obliteration
fight in front of the Baron has all five
make it out clean and head to the base
but he kills wildturtle Reggie goes down
as well no rectum available we've got a
four be free right now cocoon lands on
Osiris the damage still coming across
vixen up here fighters and here comes
repeal again all the crescendo his
Freeman Cyrus under fire puffs no need
to Stillwell go down yes he finally says
is three for one DLC
you don't need it it's taking so much
cuz I'll turn on seven just a minute
with me it goes it turtle well shut up
goes down double kill triple jeopardy
end in the minion will do everything
Cyrus can you do it
more damage there are so many minions
right now the many ways respond can side
are a little bit of timer but it's not
enough counter logic gaming in 60
minutes that has to be the craziest GOG
vs TSM game I have ever seen
they stumble has continued melting
through his HP that's a triple kill he
gets excited the risk of still just
going onto the Nexus turret unless
someone gets pulled out by the distance
and for voice kicks times backwards
children is secured that is a Quadra
kill
[Applause]
for sure Riley get the Penta his David
like I did not believe that was going to
happen and double it because 12 1 4 2 0
the kill secured he also gets the
children X's himself 5 for CLG have been
lawful clearly I'm not happy with with
where we're at right now
ten intended like if again shoved as a
bid blasted in Africa playing it like he
likes to get himself right the middle to
break a huge disengage with that box
from kiwi-kid looks like they might be
able to pick themselves up a nap for Abu
and the caustic spittle hits for the
kill coming from PewDiePie what are you
kidding me that was a four-man yeah
perfect disengage and then the hooks
gets thrown out in all decay on and only
rat in a kill one poor man's offer dig
that didn't even happen you to Sela for
you can just go split push out there's
too many of those in cages Kobe we
thought last time where pole-vaulter was
talking about shifter disengaging an
entire team on the cutiepie he stays
alive he did not go down to that ignite
Oh God double lift goes right into the
fight he says I may go down but it's
going to be valiantly bars have been
nullified and the Nexus to fall thirty
minutes in Game three
take the best-of-five series against
powder logic gaming
[Applause]
the relief and filed on the Dignitas
players bidding right now they can
finally relax
they've secured their fifth spot
relaxing they won't have to play in
relegation I'm pretty scared of losing
rush relegation of the the worst thing
that could possibly happen I have more
to lose than anyone else because he'll G
is my baby the way things have gone I'll
be left exploring and this is going to
be the game but the LG they make it back
into the North American LCS with a three
game strength being down two games to
begin with this is a success story they
were looking for they've proved that
they can come back the regular season
for CLG twelve and six spending the
majority of the season in second place
having two opportunities to take first
place against TSM falling in those
high-pressure games during the radiation
opening not against the wall TSM
actually blows the few summoners to get
to the right position to be in the right
spot that killed going to them but iris
is also calling that's going to be
Bulldogs are going down we are way too
close now for CLG triple kill for turtle
looking for the quad Ross is not going
to get it that time
it's a triple for double if he's looking
for
you came out of nowhere and it looked
like the fight was going to turn a DSM
sighs but double if the whole time was
free hitting that might be the game or
the limit they can hang out for a bit
and then he does have the chrono break
to get in the old situation but his
shadows now still inside so he can fight
a pro move going salami taken after he
knows he goes down he's letting the team
fight just taking the turret completely
knowing counter logic here the day
longer the double the triple kill now
coming in the og take the inhibitors
they're going to take the deck scissors
and they're going to take a trip to
world this is going to be a counter
logic gaming fighting every season since
there has been one and now taking down
Team solomid Madison Square Garden to be
your 2015 summer split champion
I'm speechless it's been years of blood
sweat tears for all of us talking about
my throat shot oh but it's truly magical
to be here thank you welcome back the
way that you think on if they can secure
this Baron because that bicep more time
oh it's maybe the time buyer of all time
buyers can he do it while he's there
it's a sight by big Eddie he steals it
the counter logic gaming it very much
still in it maybe on the path to victory
with the follow-up fight great over solo
there's our Delta heart flying in sauce
on TP but he wasn't actually able to get
parents he's not in the Nexus doesn't
even matter the expenditure came up that
big yes it does what a barn burner
darshan a few more he he gets it to go
down 42 minutes on the clock
counter logic gaming defeats immortal
the ultrafeed split is not to food
logic gaming and CLG stays alive and
Piglet has a chance to stay over that
wall even unpeeled he can do some big
damage eyes on him in these fights for
sure a piglet is definitely hyper carry
mode right now but darshan wants the
kill fish that's a little ambitious
maybe he only thought it was one he had
to have only thought it was one pp and
he could SD with the kill on two piglet
may be able to end the game and punch
their ticket to the final 35 seconds on
piglet CLG may get the chance to defend
that championship with two new members
it means the loss of Hui
it means the loss of six things against
that chance but it means a whole hell of
a lot to the returning members to get
back on that final stage counter logic
gaming takes out team liquid the
defending champions get to make the
final and defend their crowd it goes
them against mr. force a flash away to
star shot as ga gets popped around
knocked back now a Buster shot as well
just as was long advanced ahead just get
it up [ __ ] you and is out he's gonna try
to reason it all again for the reset
[Applause]
fifties popping up for me GHS can try
something 46 litre from 16
Tildy proof you can change the players
but the base from Maine and they're
going to walk to their second
consecutive North American LCS
championship it's pretty damn good I
think we all work really hard and also
hard-fought series on both sides I think
kiss I'm also played really well but we
hang out on top kids we're better they
just might dieting day does get matcha
the dragon goes down and secure by then
you believe don't you help the face in
CLG because they just secured three
looking for it and can they end on these
runs what's going to turn out and that's
it safe Cooper he's going low but he
caught a break back but double to Louise
but right now we're in the eighth
counter logic gaming with the most
unlikely victory I never doubted I'll
yield up liqueur for the engage they're
going to catch you with percent owner
Sean taking up throw the gravity will
doing a lot back with six off yeah we
are low in the frontline now can they
get anything Lord yes a second on a
scenic co-chief will not go quietly into
the night they're looking for the
children alone daddy says
plus the guardian angel Zod will they
really make it to come back they've got
five it's time to go Scoob ACLJ my queen
is 40 minutes into the game freak from
it toy bears from the narrows out eight
thousand gold with no water to fall
exotic going back in again acquittees
getting a type of the rest of series
here six eight sister Chrystie face over
to he gets an appeal for a bit of birth
them it's gifts brought up Matt's going
to die super now with a double kill CLG
bursting forward bending get the only
one sick they will fall there's a
trooper kill their going to chase it
down lawless no equal to run six eight
expensive Quadra kill get the only one
left alive with a rock CLG
show that while team liquid felon may be
undeniable their poise is unbreakable
[Music]
these quotes here he come it's gonna be
close
it's really close oh that was closer
than I thought
rain Homer now stick stay down with the
ulti blocking the follow up floor locos
man but he's not barely alive trying to
save him but six naked for rampage now
Matt's going to be taped down they also
find the kill on two golden blue and
liquid is routed again by the bear and
sealed aegis coming up
so so big they make it look very clean
CLG come up with a dominant win today
could see how happy they are
CLG man the number one team in na now a
lot of people would probably say well
what the heck why aren't they over there
got to get it done in spring split if
you want to go to rip rivals but hey but
right now they're showing up with dark
on the roster and I love to hear what he
talked about in terms of hey we're the
team known as the team play team but the
thing we're working on most right now is
continuing to work as a team
[Music]
that was the best of CLG throughout the
years what's your favorite CLG moment
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button